In this video,
we'll see how to compute the gradients
of the loss function with respect to the
parameters of the lug, urinary factors
in a conditional random fields.
So,
uh,
we are deriving the stochastic
gradient descent training algorithm for
conditional random fields and in
their chain conditional random fields.
We've seen the last function before and
now we're going to start looking at how
to compute the gradients with respect
to the different parameters of the log
linear conditional random fields.
So before we've defined the loss as the,
uh,
negative log of the probability of the
true label sequence given the inputs
sequence.
So now let's look at the gradient.
Okay.
Alright,
so we'll focus now on the gradient with
respect to the urinary luck factors.
That is a u r y k prime,
where why keep prime
can be any class labels.
So it's not necessarily the observe
class labels for any class label,
sort of partial. There it live of
the negative log of their property,
of a given sequence.
Why given some input sequence x with
respect to the urinary factor for some
arbitrary, uh, label,
why prime acquisition k is going to
be actually quite similar to the,
a gradient of the pre, uh, activation
at the output layer of a neural network.
It's going to be minus.
Okay.
The, uh, uh, the, uh, identity
function of weather. Why k?
So the Keith label and why
here is equal to y Prime K,
which is d label for which
we're considering, uh, the,
uh,
the parameters of the urinary factors
minus the probability according to our
model of actually observing for the Keith
label the actual value of y prime gay,
uh, Ford, they give an input. So again,
we have this a formula
which is essentially minus
what we would like to see,
which is a, that's a w, oh,
sorry. What we actually observe,
which is a label of white gay minus what,
uh,
we currently predict. So
we have essentially a, uh,
a term here,
which is only one when we're considering
the union factor for the correct answer.
Mine is the probability
distribution, uh, uh, the, uh,
current value for the current value of
the parameters of the conditional random
fields for the key of label.
Cause that's actually quite similar to
the neural network reactivation, uh,
uh, value add the output layer for
classification that we seen before.
So if we consider the specific case of
a conditional random feel where we have
for a given context of we just won
three different neural networks,
one that computes sum
reactivation based on the uh,
current position and other one
based on the input on the left.
And then the one based on the input on
the right, we consider the gradient,
which respect to uh,
all of these pre activation,
a function at the output layer of these
three neural networks that would give us
the following,
uh,
gradients with the minus the one hot a
vector with a one at the real value of
the label at position k minus the vector
of marginal probabilities for what the
label might be according to the,
uh,
current conditional random
fields for position. Okay.
So that's for the neural network that
looks at the input at the current position
came. And uh, if we're for the
one that's looking on the left,
well the grading is going to
be zero if k is equal to one.
So if it's not greater than one, and
that's because, uh, and four k equals one.
There is no neural net trying to predict
from x zero since zero doesn't exist.
And similarly, we have also
an indicator function, uh,
for the one that looks to the right,
uh,
so that the grain that is zero
if k is equal to capital k.
So now let's look at the
derivation for this formula, uh,
for uh, how, so let's try
to see why this is true.
Okay?
All right.
So we're looking at the partial derivative
of the negative log probability of
some vector of labels.
Why given some input x with
respect to the, uh, uh,
lug a factor, the urinary luck factor, uh,
and its value for a, some given
label. Why prime cane so gay,
it means we're looking at the
position came the sequence and right.
Prime key would be some value
between one and capital's seat.
Okay,
so, uh, here,
the only thing I've done is just write
what it is minus the log of p of y given
x for a log linear,
sorry,
for linear chain CRF.
So remember we have dialogue of
the exponential of these terms.
So we just have these terms. Once we
applied the log minus the log of zed,
because before we had dividend
divided by the partition function.
So the log of that would be minus
the log of the partition function.
Okay.
Now, uh, the gradients of this, sorry,
the partial derivative
of this whole expression,
which respect to that
term is going to be one.
If the KF label is actually y prime k,
otherwise that particular
expression is not going to be,
it's not going to appear here.
Okay.
So the gradient for any other position
then gay of these terms here is zero.
The grid, the derivative with
respect to that, uh, of that, sorry.
With respect to this,
it's also zero.
So it's only the case for the
same k which is important.
And if whyK is equal to pry prime k,
then we'll have the exactly the same term.
So the death of thousands
going to be one now.
Otherwise they're going to be zero.
And then minus that they're,
they've upped the log partition function.
Okay.
So we're just like the narrative to
this minus that narrative to have that.
Okay.
So let's do that specific term that they
would have the lug partition function.
So the derivative of the log is just
one over that one over zed types.
It of, of, of whatever we were
taking the logarithm logarithm of,
okay.
Now here I'm just riding the
expression for the partition function.
So because I've used a symbol,
why prime gay? I'll use instead.
Why prime prime for,
uh,
referring to the sequence of overs
over which I'm taking this sum here,
the nest at some.
Okay.
Now I can push the,
uh,
so did the narrative of a sum is the,
some of the derivatives,
so I can push that they're the
insight here. So right here.
So that's what I've done right here.
And now, uh, they're the,
about the uh, exponentiate UD.
Uh, some of, uh, factors
of luck, the factors, well,
it here, uh, Aau, right?
Prime K does not appear then
it's zero and it's, it won't,
it won't appear if y Prime K
is not equal in the sequence.
Y prime is not equal to right
prime prime cake. Uh, oh, sorry.
In the sequence. Why [inaudible]
if I had the position gay, uh,
it's value is not the value of
y prime gay then, uh, the, uh,
then, uh, the derivative of
that is going to be zero.
It's going in because it's going to be
constant with respect to that variable.
However,
if it does appear,
then the live of the exponential
is the exponential itself.
So it's going to be that term and times
to their develop the argument. Well,
it's just going to be one much
like it was one right here.
So essentially what we'll get is
the indicator function of weather.
Why prime case equal to y prime prime k
times the exponential of the sum of all
luck factors.
Yeah.
Now let's notice that here,
that's the numerator of the probability
to conditional problem probability in a
conditional random fields.
And that's the partition function.
So I can just,
yeah,
remove it here and just divide by here.
Okay.
And then what do I get?
Well I get that this whole term here is
just the probability of observing as the
sequence of labels,
a y prime prime law and followed by why
program to up to why pride pride the
capital k and then this here is here
and now if I think there's some
over opposite all sequences of uh,
and only consider the terms
were in all these sequences,
I won't consider the sequences such that
y prime prime k is equal to y prime k,
then I'm just summing the
probability of our sequences, uh,
which satisfied this condition.
So all sequences such that the key
element that the sequence is right,
prime came. And so there's
some of all of these, uh,
John probably is just the marginal
probability that y prime gay,
uh, is the key if label in the
sequence. So I do obtain that.
This term here is p of
y prime gay given x.
And so I do have that the gradient,
the parts of their,
they would just back to the logging area
factor is the indicator function minus
the probability under the model.
So that's great. I know, uh,
we now have the gradients of the
and the partial data they've,
with respect to the log you neri factor,
but we don't have it with respect to the
parameters in the login error factor.
Fortunately we've seen that,
uh,
the backpropagation that allows us to
very efficiently applied the chain rule
and back propagate the
gradients to all the parameters.
So essentially from the
parameters of the login,
there factors that gives me
essentially the uh, uh, uh,
the partial though the which respect to
the pre activation values at the output
layer of the neural
nets, uh, inside the CRF.
And then I can just take those gradients,
those partial derivatives and back,
propagate them towards all
the parameters of the model.
Now notice that because it's the same
neural network at each position in the
conditional random fields,
I need to accumulate all the gradients
for every position and the sequence.
So all of these greatest need to
be accumulated into, uh, the, uh,
my computation of the parameter gradients.
Okay.
So let's look at the specific
case of linear, linear chain,
conditional random fields. So the case
where the luck factors are linear. So, uh,
this will be the neural
network from the center,
the computation that looks
at the aligned input.
So it'd be in linear transformation
plus bias. Then we have the,
uh, uh, computation that looks
at, and sorry, that's a mistake.
That should be, um, oh, sorry. Yeah,
so that's one way of writing it.
I could have written it came out
is one here and k minus one here.
I could have rhythm Kate bus one here.
Keep the last one here.
But let's just assume now
that, uh, we have this, uh,
lug linear model where the, uh, uh,
urinary luck factors are just linear
function of the context window.
Yeah.
So in this, the, uh, Great
Edward, respect to the bias.
And also,
I just want to say that notice I didn't
put a bias here or here and that's
because I would just be redundant
since, uh, I mean just a single bias,
uh,
is sufficient.
So the greatest of respect of
the bias would be the gradient,
uh, with respect to the, uh, uh,
pre activation function, uh,
for the center of the window,
but summed over all positions.
So that's the green of the activation
function at our position case or for all
inputs xk all position can't actually,
and we've seen before that the gradient
was essentially this the one hot vector
minus the vector of marginal
probabilities for the position gain.
So I'm just summing over all positions
game and now if only the greatest of
respect to the weights,
uh,
that connects the input that's
at the current position.
K or that's to the left or to the right?
Well,
I get something that's essentially
very similar. It's again,
the a 100 vector minus the vector
marginal probabilities. But for,
uh, this part of the Pr,
this parameter Matrix,
I'm also surprised by the transpose
of the vector aligned with the current
position. K. This one I multiplied
by the vector to the left,
the transpose of the vector to the left,
and he transposed to the
of the vector to the right.